more than 90,000 residents of Miami
Beach have been ordered to leave it is
the city's largest evacuation since
Hurricane Wilma in 2005 we spoke earlier
to Mayor Philip Levine who calls the
storm a nuclear hurricane we asked him
if his community is prepared we're as
prepared as any city can be with this
type of devastating historic hurricane I
call it a nuclear hurricane really
because of the incredible horrible
damage it's done all the way through the
Caribbean islands on its way to Florida
literally we put in portable pumps
portable generators we've been working
to identify our homeless population our
seniors of course our special needs
people we've organized buses trolleys
everything to make sure we can evacuate
everybody from Miami Beach mr. mayor
there are always questions about what to
do about those who refuse to evacuate
what is Miami gonna do well we're trying
everything we can to convince them even
on a broadcast like this I make a
special appeal to our residents or any
visitors that happen to be here get out
of Miami Beach we don't need heroes
we're all about safety your safety leave
Miami Beach this is a small low-lying
barrier island this hurricane is of a
magnitude and strength of historical
proportions we need people to leave the
beach because what's going to happen is
as this hurricane moves down the track
as it begins to hit Miami Beach and west
of Miami our first responders will be
unable to go out we will not put their
jeopardy of their lives in jeopardy of
course and on that note mr. mayor Monroe
County officials down in the keys say
that no one will answer 911 I know one
calls the answer to a Miami Beach well
we're gonna do the best we can and of
course our county has a number which is
called three one one four information as
well but we know we have to understand
and anyone who's listening to this this
is something that it's so powerful so
strong there is no upside for you to
stay on Miami Beach
there's nothing but downside I know you
mentioned encourage people to go to the
shelters in Miami Day but it's my
understanding that they only have room
for about a hundred thousand people is
there enough space yeah there's a lot of
space available but what happens is a
lot of people who decided to leave early
a lot of people have left Miami a lot of
folks have gone west gone north a lot of
people have gone to relatives friends
houses where they feel safer so at this
point right now we believe there's
plenty of space in our shell
and I encourage people get to one of our
shelters now because the window is
fastly closing one of the great problems
is always flooding well your pumping
stations somehow ameliorate that kind of
damage absolutely not you know I tell
people the pumps we put in and all our
generators therefore sea-level rise
which we experience here and of course
with a moderate rain they are no match
for a hurricane let alone hurricane Irma
which is packing one heck of a punch
Florida is known for its beautiful
beaches it's also known for its large
elderly population what are you doing to
ensure the safety of those who cannot
physically leave their homes because of
their age our fire department our first
responders have gone out we've met with
the various buildings that that house a
lot of our elderly we've made sure we
could get them and bring them over to
shelters and assist it every way we
possibly could I've gone out I know the
elderly population here very very well
and so we have made sure that we could
aggressively push them and move them out
of Miami Beach I know your fiancee is in
her third trimester where will the two
of you be riding out the storm I'm gonna
be in Miami Beach I'm gonna be at Mount
Sinai Hospital and we're making a
decision right now for her if it's best
for her to stay in the hospital or its
best for her to move off the beach well
we wish you and all the residents there
and all of Florida the best of luck
thank you so much for joining us mayor
thank you very much as the mayor said
they do not need heroes everybody should
leave